hello everyone thank you for joining us
for the fifth annual clinical
diagnostics and research online
conference
life technologies the brand of thermo
fisher scientific is a proud sponsor of
today's webinar series
where we will focus on presentations
themed around unraveling the complexity
of oncology research my name is sandy
hammer and i'm a marketing specialist
here i'll be your moderator for today's
presentation
and i'm proud to introduce dr emma
bowden who will be our second speaker in
this week's series
dr bowden is the director of
translational medicine here at thurbo
fisher scientific she leads the
compendia bioscience bioinformatics
services group to provide custom
bioinformatics solutions
for oncology drug development and
research
today dr bowden will speak on the
identification of predictive biomarkers
from high throughput drug combination
screening data
at the end of the presentation i will be
facilitating q a so please feel free to
submit questions on the screen during
the presentation
and now i would like to turn it over to
dr bowden for her presentation
thank you sandy um as sandy mentioned
i'm going to be walking you through
today some of the approaches and
pipelines that we have built that allow
us to systematically identify uh
predictive biomarkers for response and
synergy
that indicate uh enhanced response to
drug combinations and identifying
biomarkers that allow us to then also
identify biomarkers to enrich and
identify clinical populations that are
potentially going to respond to these
unique combinations
why do we need and use predictive
biomarkers uh it's become clear i think
over the last few years uh that uh many
of the strategies that have been used
particularly with the emerging targeted
therapies uh have not been uh
potentially as successful as we would
have liked them to have been uh this is
particularly true when used uh in a uh
an unselected population where uh you
know we are often not seeing the types
of response rate that would allow us to
move drugs through forwarding forward in
a pipeline to approval and use in a
clinical setting what's become clear
over the last few years as i mentioned
is that
often the use of biomarkers
so to identify particular genomic status
in subsets of patients in a particular
indication
can allow us to select and identify
patients that potentially have an
enhanced response to certain targeted
therapies and i think key examples of
this uh type of opportunity can be
highlighted by
things like for example
her2
amplified status in breast cancer as a
biomarker for herceptin treatment
and even more recently uh the emerging
story about raz mutation status in
colorectal patients being an indicator
for lack of response to
monoclonal antibody therapy targeting
egfr receptor in that indication and i
think more and more now we're starting
to see some
pretty interesting emerging trial design
that allows us to potentially fully
exploit the variety of biomarkers that
can be found in patient populations and
actually tailor treatment strategies
based on these biomarker selections to
improve response rate in
our in our indications of interest
and so what i'm going to be talking
about today is a little bit of some of
the work that we've been doing to
identify biomarkers both to single agent
treatments but i'm also going to focus
particularly on a newer more emerging
area for us which really focuses on how
to
address this type of approach for
combination strategies
so when we look at
the sort of overall process uh that we
would apply to this type of strategy um
you know you you can take uh the
strategy of of uh
looking at clinical data in a
retrospective manner to identify
biomarkers
from patient data and response data that
perhaps in retrospect would have allowed
a good patient selection or enrichment
strategy the other opportunity here
though really is very early on in a
program a drug program development
strategy to start to think uh early
about the potential biomarkers of
response either to single agent or to
and to
also try to start to identify
opportunities for identification of the
optimal combination in a clinical
setting and this is important because
many of the drugs
in use and that are being developed are
are not going to see patients as single
agent treatments they will of course be
used in combination strategies and many
of the drug companies now are
actually developing a very innovative uh
strategies to
uh combine uh novel novel therapeutics
and the fda in the last few years has
also released uh a
guidances on how to tackle and address
this type of challenge so it's
definitely an emerging area of interest
and what we've been interested in doing
is uh designing and driving uh
approaches to uh help make this uh as
successful as possible
from a pre-clinical standpoint then
there there are a number of stages to
this type of approach
and what i'm going to do is walk you
through uh today at a very high level
some of the major considerations for
this type of work
and
some of the challenges as well as some
of the opportunities and uh the slide
really really sort of designates a
number of uh uh
pieces of work that we do along this uh
pipeline to this type of project
starting with cell line panel design
we recognize this can be done in a very
agnostic way with large cell line panels
and we have done this very successfully
in the past and i'll address this to
some extent but there's also a place
here for
designing very specific panels to
address
particular diseases of interest to
identify and address very
specific biomarker hypotheses
and
once you've designed these panels uh the
next stage is to go on to uh generating
cell line response data
this is typically something we do we
have been doing in collaboration with a
number of uh external partners
and i'll i'll touch on these a little
bit uh later um but uh
really what we're generating here is uh
data
uh of response or resistance synergy and
antagonism
um and we can tailor how we uh
generate and use these data
utilizing uh custom endpoints multiple
different strategies all again to
exploit and maximize the opportunity to
identify uh biomarkers of response and
to find the best opportunity to take
forward uh into uh proposing and
building uh
um
sort of the clinical opportunities that
you would hope to get from this type of
from this type of data
um the next stage once we generate cell
line response data is to look at uh
biomarkers associated with the single a
single agent
we would then also uh in a setting where
we're generating combination data as
well as single agent data we would
identify biomarkers for both single
agent and for uh all of the combinations
being screened this is interesting
because the uh biomarkers for
combinations uh for identifying synergy
are often uh can be quite different from
uh the
biomarkers a single agent and they have
different slightly different use cases
and i'll touch on this a little bit as
we go through the presentation
and then importantly i think um the next
stage of this project once we've
identified these biomarkers is to take
what we call a clinical mapping strategy
so we
look at these biomarkers and we look at
their prevalence and penetrance
in
both the diseases of interest uh and
more broadly to potentially expand uh
clinical opportunities um by using
biomarkers and as i'll mention later it
the biomarkers we identify from this
type of approach can be very useful in
identifying an enrichment strategy in a
particular disease
what we found is that these biomarkers
can also be very useful in identifying
novel clinical opportunities and in some
cases opportunities that
actually
may not need the biomarker
to stratify patients once you've
identified a disease
that has a very
high overall favorable biomarker profile
and so i'll touch on these as we walk
through this is a
starting point overview of the things
i'm going to touch on and some of the
considerations that we'll discuss as we
go through uh the whole deck
and to help put some of this into
context we have uh you know there are a
set of very um sort of typical use case
questions that um that were asked um and
these are several of them uh which
we can use to sort of highlight the use
and uh the types of approach that we can
take and the types of approach we can
use to tailor these uh um projects to
best address the key questions for an
individual client and
the questions that are pertinent to
their drug program
so for example what new opportunities
exist in the standard of care drug
refractory segments of my disease of
interest
so in this case for example if we hark
back to uh what i mentioned earlier
where we
recognize uh in colorectal cancer that
um raz mutation uh is uh
a biomarker for lack of response to an
egfr targeted
antibody
then this is not this question could be
tailored in that context to say what
combinations potentially would allow us
to overcome
the uh
resistance that is being introduced by
constitutive activation of the map
kinase pathway and so we can tailor the
design of these experiments to
specifically address that type of
question
and
address uh something which not only has
uh high significant clinical relevance
but is also uh creating or expanding uh
clinical opportunities and competitive
opportunities for a drug program
um what biomarkers identify potential
patient populations my drug and what
other aberrations also occur in that
population again this is somewhat
similar perhaps to the last
question but again
allows you to start to identify where
you may have unique opportunities by
relatively high frequency genomic events
that occur in subsets of your disease of
interest
something we see quite often is we've
clients that have
uh
come to us with some initial success in
a clinical setting in a relatively
limited scope of a particular cancer
type so in this case for example i'm
proposing uh hematopoietic cancers
and they're looking to try to find an
opportunity to get into a solid tumor
setting so maybe they've done some
exploratory work in uh perhaps even in
an early
phase one phase two trial
but have not seen the type of success
that they're looking for again we can
actually based on the mechanism of
action of their drug
and the diseases of interest
we can actually help design experiments
to uh help
drive the answer to this type of
question and create opportunities and
then obviously
the last question here which drug
combinations will increase the efficacy
or uh frankly uh induced synergy when
combined with
the drug from your
development program and uh you know i
think importantly
um
identifying uh synergy for a particular
combination
does not guarantee that all of the
patients in the indication uh will
respond so there is still a definitely a
clear opportunity to understand
which subsets of patients in an
indication are going to respond or not
respond to a particular combination
setting and so these are very important
questions from a translational
perspective and whilst there are some
limitations to uh generating data in a
pre-clinical setting there is a lot of
power to these approaches in terms of
generating hypotheses
that can be tested
and being able to narrow the scope and
field of opportunity to best identify
opportunities for success
so with that i'm going to walk you
through and show you um a few
examples and start to explain a little
bit more about how we think about these
types of experiments
so there are there are two settings
where
we
often are analyzing data from these
types of experiments
um
one setting would be uh use of a single
agent screened across a very large
multi-cancer cell line panel
historically we have worked and
continued to work very closely with
european pan lab they have a large 240
cell line
multi-cancer cell line panel that many
of our clients use for generating
pre-clinical pharmacology data
this type of screen that includes cell
lines as i mentioned from many different
uh cancer types
can be
incredibly useful for
identifying very initial predictive
biomarker hypotheses
it's also very good for building a
preliminary understanding of your single
agent efficacy and can be used to start
to identify uh some
opportunities for
diseases that are potentially going to
respond to your drug
in a drug combination setting
what we've found is that this is an
opportunity to
address a focused biomarker hypothesis
or or a very specific uh disease of
interest so if a large single agent
screen across a a cell line panel allows
you to identify two or three
large indication of interest and we know
that those indications uh potentially
have quite a
quite a broad spectrum of genetic and
genomic diversity
so for example if we were to address
lung cancer
you know the different subsets of lung
cancer
have very different
profiles from a genomic standpoint and
very different clinical treatment
strategies associated with them
so typically what we found is uh you
know one agent across a large panel is a
great way to start to identify where
your opportunities might be
and in an ideal world you would also use
very large
uh cell line panels for drug combination
screening
uh however uh the
cost and the amount of data that has to
be analyzed from these experiments can
be prohibitive
so typically what we found is a more
focused
biomarker targeted panel or a
disease-specific panel with fewer cell
lines
allows you to address and refine the
biomarker hypotheses from the single
agent screen
uh again now it allows you to identify
synergistic drug combinations that are
relevant to diseases of interest from a
clinical development standpoint
um and uh are more limited in scope in
terms of the amount of data that has to
be uh analyzed to uh
understand the opportunities and this is
challenging uh you know as i mentioned
for single agent screening where we work
often with um eurofin pan lab for drug
combination screening we're working very
closely with a company called zalicus
they have a high throughput combination
screening platform and i'll talk a
little bit more about that
but in this setting what we're doing
typically is screening a smaller cell
line panel with your compound of
interest
in combination with up to 200 relevant
oncology compounds and this generates
enormous amounts of data
and so this is typically
kind of how we think about the
use case and challenges for
the various approaches and how they can
be tailored to addressing very specific
drug development questions
so if we get into the specifics a little
bit the first uh one of the early phases
here for this uh type of work and
predominantly i'm going to be focusing
on combination screening
is really about
is about this cell line panel design as
i mentioned in an ideal world
we would be able to screen across very
large cell line panels with hundreds of
enhancer compounds
to identify all of the potentially
impactful synergistic combinations
in a real world setting we often have to
tailor this back and design small cell
line panels to support
targeted screens
and so typically what we're looking here
is to identify cell line panels from the
indications of interest what we need to
support this type of analysis is the
full genomic profile of those cell lines
including
mutation copy number expression fusions
and
recently
much of this data has become publicly
available and we also continue to
profile cell lines
to
build up this database of information
importantly not all cell lines and
indications are particularly amenable to
high throughput uh screening so growth
characteristics does have impact on the
choice of cell lines and again we work
closely with our collaborators to
manage this particular parameter
and
the
biomarker status or the genomic profile
of the cell line
of cell lines that you're looking at is
one piece of the puzzle
being able to put these cell lines into
the context of uh the clinically
relevant aberrations uh in disease is a
very important piece of this puzzle and
we spend quite a lot of time thinking
about that and i'll touch on it a little
bit further
so compendia has spent uh the last
probably the last uh six seven years
aggregating uh and building an
understanding of the world's genomic
data
over that time we have brought in data
from many different uh public sources
and proprietary sources
and have built a very good understanding
of the profile of clinical samples
across very many disease types
and
built a number of tools and environments
and databases which we make available to
both the academic community and to
the non-academic community in various
forms and these databases are
interrogatable and
support a variety of different workflows
that allow you to ask questions about
different aberration types or diseases
or specific targets
but in this case for this particular
type of analysis we lean very heavily on
this data
because what we want to do is
build cell line panels that are relevant
to the clinical
disease setting
if you
don't take uh the the
if you don't take into consideration
what's happening in a clinical setting
the results you get from this type of
screening may not be relevant to what
you're going to encounter uh when you
take your drug into clinic and so uh you
know as well as aggregating data from
many different cancer types uh we have
uh probably over uh with genomic profile
data of various types on over 90 000
patient samples across 150 diseases
we've also brought in aggregated similar
data and data types
from many of the large cell line panels
and have data i think on well over 1200
cell line panels xenographs and
and can now also aggregate that data and
we sort of pull it all together in what
we call our biomarker databases so we
have a clinical tumor biomarker database
we all have also have a cell line by
marker database
but what we need to do is overlay these
two things
as i mentioned to pick models that are
relevant to disease and this has very
disease specific considerations so for
example um
you know we we recognize uh in this case
you know there are many folks that are
interested in being able to interrogate
and understand uh the used case and
maximum applicability for inhibitors of
both the map kinase and pi3 kinase
pathway we also recognize there are a
number of companies
and academicians that are interested in
understanding the best way to combine
inhibitors for these two pathways
and this slide is just showing you a
snapshot of some of the data that we
have aggregated on clinical samples
this is actually all uh mgs data
and uh the panel on the left here is
showing the overall frequency of
aberrations for
pi3 kinase pathway and map kinase
pathway in a variety of
diseases
the bars are stacked here so you can see
the frequency of occurrence
for aberration in each of those pathways
on a per disease basis and as you start
to scan down this chart what you can see
is that uh clearly some of these
diseases have quite different profiles
so
the diseases a couple of the diseases
here
where the bars are predominantly blue or
in some cases almost exclusively blue
these are diseases that we recognize
from our data are very much driven by
the map kinase pathway um and whereas uh
you know there are additional diseases
for example so a couple of the breast
uh breast cancer
disease subtypes here that we've
captured
are pretty much exclusively driven uh by
aberrations in the pi3 kinase pathway
now this is not taking into account all
of the genomic aberrations in the just
in these diseases what we focus on here
are just the frequency of occurrence of
aberrations uh from either from our
definition of the map kinase and pi3
kinase pathway and to give you a little
bit of a flavor of what that means
we've uh highlighted over here in a
couple of diseases the um
the uh
occurrence of um
uh individual aberrations in these two
pathways are in a couple of different
diseases
and you can see uh for example
we have
on the left here
what we have is uh
the frequency of aberrations in these
diseases in colorectal cancer perhaps
unsurprisingly we recognize as a pretty
high frequency occurrence of k-ras
mutations in colorectal cancer
and in squamous uh you know there are
reasonably high frequency vibrations in
kinase pathway genes but are not
necessarily the same genes
so in this case uh there are there is a
frequency of occurrence of k-ra's
mutation um but uh
it tends to be other members of the
pathway that are
mutated and activating uh
in
in this disease and the next level of
detail on this is when you start to look
at individual diseases at uh
co-occurrence and mutual exclusivity
the top panel here for example what
we're looking at here is our individual
patients are represented in the bars
again we have individual family members
from both
the pi3 kinase and kinase pathway and
what we're looking at is uh mutual
exclusivity or co-occurrence uh for
these aberrations in an individual
patient and for example at the top here
we have aberrations that are
occurring with relatively high frequency
in both map kinase and pi3 kinase
in colorectal cancer there are a number
of patients that only have operations in
one pathway
but this is a quite high frequency for
co-occurrence of aberrations in both
pathways whereas in squamous lung
where we're seeing uh quite a high drive
of aberrations in pi3-kinase pathway but
very few co-occurring mutations in the
map kinase pathway and so again uh
understanding this diversity
understanding where and when there are
diseases that you see aberrations
relatively frequently in pathways that
have been shown frankly to potentially
contribute to uh
resistance to uh inhibiting uh the the
other pathway
these are very important things to know
and understand uh in the diseases of
interest as you start to
try to build an understanding of where
you're going from a clinical setting and
what major considerations have to be
taken into account
for you to be successful in that setting
and knowing all of this now allows you
to
address very carefully the the concepts
that you need to take on board when you
design a cell line panel to address some
of these specific challenges at a
genomic level again with the idea that
thinking about these things early allows
you to build your program for success
because you can address some of these
potential challenges head on
the other consideration here uh the
other piece of this puzzle uh is uh
the the statistical question uh around
what is required to build these
experiments for success so we've talked
about what's necessary from a biological
and conceptual perspective
there is the practical though of uh how
many cell lines do you need to use
to be successful if you're going to try
to design a panel to take on a biomarker
challenge head on
what is the minimum panel design
that you need for that how many times
does your biomarker have to be
represented in that panel to potentially
be able to discover that biomarker uh as
a marker or synergy or response
and what we've done to address this is
we've uh we've taken on a power analysis
uh in concept it's relatively
straightforward
uh and the we have a snapshot here that
just uh shows you
some of the analysis we've done to
recognize what our minimum panel size
would be and what the minimum
numbers of biomarker representations for
a particular biomarker would need to be
in that panel
to understand and be able to
statistically identify that biomarker is
associated with sensitivity or
resistance or synergy or even antagonism
and so the approach here is uh the axis
across the top is the um is the number
of cell lines
um and so we scaled everything from very
small cell line panel i think the top
end we're capturing about 50 or 60 cell
lines here
um the
y-axis here is recognizing the number of
cell lines that are
either
responsive or synergistic or resistant
and what this analysis tells us is that
um you know there's a cut off probably
at about uh 25 cell lines
um
that uh where below which you start to
run the risk of being able to uh
statistically
biomarker associations with
uh with your call strategy so
sensitivity or resistance or antagonism
synergy and so it
what happens here is so if we pick
a square
so let's say we're in about the ballpark
of 10 or 11 cell lines here and of those
10 or 11 cell lines uh some number of
sensitive and some number are resistant
and some number have uh across that
panel of 10 cell lines they are all
either positive or wild type for the
biomarker in question
we use a fischer's exact test to uh
essentially run every combination
uh of sensitive and resistant for a cell
line panel of that size
and calculate then whether or not based
on uh the number of sensitive and
resistant calls whether it's possible
for us to identify a statistical
association and so at about 25 cell
lines about a panel of the 25 cell lines
we start to get to the get to a place
where we get beyond the boundaries of
not being able to identify statistical
associations
in yellow we start to see that that we
can identify at least one statistically
significant association and obviously as
the cell line panels get larger it gets
easier and easier to identify
uh
specific biomarkers that are associated
with one call strategy or another and so
these are very important considerations
if you have a biomarker hypothesis or uh
that needs to be addressed because of
your particular mechanism and what's
already known these are very important
considerations to take into account
so just to highlight again what we've
talked about in terms of panel selection
we have uh you know we can design panels
either for specific diseases and
recognize within those the design of
those panels the genomic diversity that
we know should be represented in that
disease
or we can take on histology specific
panels or biomarker specific panels and
so there's a there's a variety of things
that we can do to be tailored to the
needs
and the clinical considerations of a
program
at the next stage what we're looking at
now is assessing cell line response so
we've designed our panel and now we're
looking at the response of draw of each
of those cell lines to the combination
treatment
um and as again i mentioned working with
zalicas they have a an oncology relevant
uh panel of compounds uh with about 200
oncology relevant enhancer compounds so
our cell line panel and uh the uh in the
uh base compound now uh uh are being
screened for effects on uh cell line
growth or other end points uh
both in single agent and with up to in
this case up to 200 oncology relevant
cancers and what we do is assess this
data and generate
a variety of scores we can look at
self-cross data on the cell lines and
use that essentially
as a normalization strategy so that we
can look across all of the cell lines
and all of the drugs and aggregate the
data to
drive biomarker discovery
the xylicus high throughput screening
platform um is a very powerful platform
that allows us to uh essentially
identify and take on board
uh
and
identify synergy uh
as manifested in either
or both potency shifts and or efficacy
boosts
and they have a proprietary software
that allows analysis of this data
they have a number of strategies to be
able to
customize the approaches they take to
analyzing this data to support custom
endpoints custom analysis strategies or
to focus on specifically uh one or the
other of these potential
enhancements of response that can be
identified in combination screening so
they have a very flexible screening and
a very flexible analysis platform which
puts
us all in a very strong position to
maximize the potential of this data at
this point they have a collection of
about 800 cell lines and we are also
working with them very closely to expand
this
panel
to address uh specific uh diseases of
interest and certain biomarkers that we
know are very clinically relevant we
want to make sure that those are uh
included in their panel and we continue
to work very closely with them on the
build out of that data
their analysis platform uh is as i
mentioned is very flexible you know they
have this large compound library they
have large panels of cell lines so now
as you look across all of this data
you can start to understand uh
overall
patterns of response and synergy
with certain cell lines and certain
enhancers or certain classes or certain
grouped
common mechanisms of enhancer in the
panel
as well as being able to identify
synergy and lack of synergy
another aspect of this that's very
powerful is the ability to also identify
antagonism
which again as i mentioned makes us very
powerful and uh our analysis based on
this data allows us to customize and
take into account these various
endpoints so we can look for just
biomarkers of synergy we can also look
to try to identify biomarkers or
antagonism and so again we have a lot of
flexibility in terms of how we can
analyze this data
um when we start to think about
uh you know
the the
data from that we received from from
xylicus in particular uh gives us the
synergy scores and the self-cross data
we now start to look at this data in
aggregate and so what we've done in this
example uh here is uh is is we've rank
ordered the cell lines that have been
screened uh in this case with a uh
map kinase and pi3 kinase inhibitor
combination
uh we've rank ordered them from uh the
highest normalized synergy score to the
lowest normalized synergy score in this
case we are recognizing synergy and
non-synergy not antagonism
and we use a number of potential
approaches to be able to cluster and
label sets of cell lines from this data
now as either responsive or resistant or
in this case synergistic and
non-synergistic and so uh this is the
same waterfall plot so this is the same
data that's been rank ordered uh what
i've overlaid on here though are two
different call strategies for this data
and this becomes important because uh
you know the the uh every drug
combination behaves slightly differently
and we want to maximize the opportunity
for discovering biomarkers that help us
understand this synergy and help us
understand uh take these by how to take
these biomarkers forward and utilize
them in a clinical setting
and so typically we'll assess multiple
call strategies and generate preliminary
assessments of the numbers of biomarkers
that are associated with each of these
call strategies uh and in this case uh
what we've done i think here is overlaid
uh the two call strategies here are uh i
think two standard deviations from the
self cross
uh median and three standard deviations
uh from the same uh
analyzed in the same way and you can see
that uh the the two standard deviation
grabs considerably more cell lines that
are synergistic the three standard
deviation uh cut off grabs less cell
lines that are synergistic so it's a
more stringent cutoff we typically would
also look for
what we consider to be biological breaks
in the data
so we for example we we would pay
attention to the fact that there is
clearly a small subset of cell lines
here that have a quite different
response to the rest of the panel again
though the two most
uh
synergistic cell lines here there's only
two of them and bearing in mind some of
the considerations that we just went
through in terms of the numbers of cell
lines that we need uh to be able to
identify statistically significant
biomarkers this illustrates i think why
just grabbing the two most synergistic
cell lines here may not create a
biomarker opportunity for us and why we
grab
multiple
potential cutoffs in this data to try to
maximize our opportunity to discover
biomarkers
the other parameter here that's very
important for us is understanding the
relevance of the concentration of the
drugs that are being used so what we
also do
and in this case we used somewhat
arbitrary cutoff of one micromolar we
want to understand how many of the cell
lines uh that have been called
synergistic are only called synergistic
at concentrations that are perhaps above
what the physiologically relevant
concentration of drug would be and this
is true for both the base compound and
also for the enhancers and this is
something that we take into account at
later stages of the project
as we look across the whole panel uh we
also want to make sure as we look and
aggregate this data that we're not
seeing any cell lines that are uniformly
responsive
and so are perhaps showing some kind of
enhanced baseline sensitivity to uh
carrier
molecule or
carrier substance in the disease in the
drugs that are being tested so we uh we
definitely pay some attention to this at
early stages of the project
we can also pay attention to um drugs or
similar mechanism we would anticipate uh
that similar cell lines or that we would
see a similar set of cell lines
responding in a similar way to drugs of
related mechanism this also becomes a
good
sense check and cross of the data and
does start to also reveal some
interesting things uh in the results
once we've gone through this phase
though it's the the uh designation of
cells of synergistic or non-synergistic
or synergistic and antagonistic is very
important because once you make these
categorical calls we now move on to
biomarker discovery which is where we
integrate these calls with the genomic
data so this is where we start to find
and power the biomarker associations
that recognize and call out how and why
these synergistic interactions have
occurred
and we call on a number of different
biomarker types including mutation
amplifications deletions expression we
generate custom gene signatures and we
do all this for in both a univariate and
a multivariate way again to allow us to
maximize the potential of the biomarkers
that we've identified and really
understand the potential use case for
biomarkers that we find
and again this is a an example uh of an
analysis using a combination of pi3
kinase and map kinase inhibitors
we did see
several biomarkers that were
significant and in particular generated
a synergy
transcriptional signature that was very
strongly associated with
synergy in the cell line panel that was
tested
this is the waterfall plot of response
again this is a synergy score for
individual cell lines rank ordered from
the highest synergy score to the lowest
synergy score the call strategy that was
used to generate and identify biomarkers
associated with synergistic versus
non-synergistic cell lines
and now we have designated a minimum
threshold of expression for this synergy
signature
in each of the individual cell lines and
have overlaid that onto this response
data so you can see that
we have a a pretty good ability
with this signature to recognize uh at
this using this high threshold to
recognize the cell lines that were uh
were synergistic
now you can imagine with even with a
small cell line panel with up to 200
combinations you potentially identify
very large numbers of biomarkers
this is actually been a little bit of a
surprise to us just how rich
the results from this type of analysis
can be and we have come up with
a prioritization strategy that allows us
to kind of triage through these
biomarkers and identify what we think
are the strongest opportunities with the
strongest set of evidence based on a
number of statistical parameters
including
p and q value performance where the
individual biomarkers come out in
multivariate analysis in decision tree
the sensitivity and specificity of these
biomarkers against the cell line
response data and so we sort of built
this uh categorization methodology to
allow us to triage through this and uh
it disallows the
most what we think are the most
important findings to kind of float to
the top of the pack and allows us to
help uh sort of structure and present
these findings to our client and help
them understand how and why we would
favor certain uh biomarker results over
others
once we've identified these biomarkers
the next piece is to
understand their occurrence and
prevalence in our
clinical database so we map these
biomarkers into our clinical database
and uh this allows us both to understand
uh whether or not the biomarkers are
actually needed in a clinical setting
and can also allow us to identify
additional potential opportunities for
further investigation in either a
pre-clinical or a clinical setting
after this so to give you an example of
what this looks like um in the one of
the previous slides i showed you the uh
synergy the transcriptional signature
that was indicative of a a
high synergy uh for a combination of a
map kinase and pi3 kinase pathway and
what we've done uh in this analysis we
have a database with about 30 000 uh
clinical samples uh all expression based
data or predominantly expression based
data
and what we've done here is uh
the signatures that we've generated uh
every gene in the signature is uh
z-score normalized and then we use the
average z-score for each gene in the
signature
to
essentially identify
a
signature score for every individual
patient so
in this plot what we see here is uh
every dot
that's represented in this chart is an
individual patient
that in this case has been scored for
two signatures
so it has been scored for the pi3 kinase
map kinase on the ps3 kinase mech
synergy signature that we identified as
a biomarker for synergy
when combining these two classes of
inhibitor
and we've actually overlaid that onto a
signature that
we believe
very strongly represents
a signature that identifies
a
lack of response or even resistance to a
mech inhibitor
and so
we have about 150 different diseases
represented uh in this they are rolled
up and represented as
the general cancer type level here the
cancer types are
represented in the uh
colors on the right uh so we end up with
this kind of colorful snowball of uh
samples again where each uh each dot is
a patient sample and the frequencies of
samples now that occurring that have uh
what we've represented here is samples
with a very high resistance signature
but also a very high synergy score
and so
and those diseases are represented here
with the frequency and i believe this is
above the medium for each one of these
signatures so this suggests that there
are fractions of patients from certain
diseases that we would predict are going
to be resistant to a mech inhibitor
alone or mount kinase pathway inhibitor
alone but are potentially sensitive to
the combination of a pi3 kinase and map
kinase inhibitor this starts to provide
an illustration of how this type of data
can be used and if we break this a
little further down to the individual
cancer type level just to highlight one
example for you here
this is the same cloud of samples from
the previous slide but now what we've
overlaid on here is just uh diseases
subtypes from
brain and cns tumors
and what becomes apparent uh quite
quickly here is that we have a couple of
diseases from this general cancer type
that are behaving quite differently in
terms of their expression profile for
these biomarkers
so for example in the green here
we have glioblastoma and uh
you know so
this the the high frequency of
occurrence of this disease subtype here
suggests that glioblastoma is
potentially sensitive to the combination
of pi3 kinase and map kinase inhibitor
whereas uh in this uh uh orange color
down here with very nice segregation
where the majority of neuroblastoma
samples uh have a very high expression
of a map kinase resistance signature
mech resistance signature suggesting
they're potentially not going to be
resistant to mech but throwing a pi3
kinase inhibitor on top of that kinase
inhibitor in this disease is not
necessarily going to make sense um
because uh you know our data would
suggest that uh you you are not
necessarily going to see a response to
this combination at least on the basis
of uh these uh this expression based
biomarker this is how we start to
generate these hypotheses for our
clients some of them as i mentioned can
be further explored by uh extending the
pre-clinical testing and uh and some of
them we have found are potentially
immediately actionable either because
we've identified uh biomarkers where
assays uh already exist because they're
being used as biomarkers in other
diseases um
or and or because uh there are disease
uh there are uh uh inhibitors uh that
are already being used or potentially
clinically approved um and the
combination of these things actually
allows you to identify something which
is potentially immediately clinically
actionable and could potentially be
impactful enough that it's worth
considering going immediately to uh
at least small-scale clinical testing
um so
with that uh you know we recognize that
both initial and acquired resistance
as well as patient progression
really highlights the need for
combination treatment strategies this is
also true as i mentioned at the
beginning because no drug is used in
isolation very few drugs are used as
single agent
we believe that
exploiting and using in a uh
in a
hypothesis driven carefully designed way
that uh preclinical data can be a very
very powerful tool to support uh
combination therapy and clinical trial
design hypotheses
the offering we've been talking about
today or some of the work i've been
describing to you today uh is something
that we've been uh we call a combo
predictor offering our single agent
approach to this is something we call an
onco predictor
combo predictor though is something that
we do as i mentioned jointly and in
close collaboration with uh the great
team uh at zalicus
and we believe that this offering and
this approach enables us to identify
potentially synergistic therapy
combinations
to identify biomarkers a synergy and
then ultimately to identify
tumor populations that are enriched with
these biomarkers enabling and driving a
rational clinical drug design strategy
with improved opportunity for success
and with that i'm going to
say thank you very much for your time
and your attention and uh hopefully if
sandy has received some questions we can
address them in the last few minutes
indeed um
i'd like to thank you dr bowden for your
presentation and for everyone for
attending today and asking good
questions we do have a couple here
we
when you do
do you also look for bile markers for
treatment of resistance among existing
drugs
yes that's something we we can do we
have brought in quite a lot of data uh
that has been generated publicly uh for
uh single agent screening uh for quite a
variety of different therapies and many
targeted therapies we have
systematically gone through and
identified uh biomarkers of both uh
response and resistance to those single
agent
treatments
that allows us also to
help build hypotheses
and can be very useful in understanding
uh potential
considerations for combination strategy
in some cases we also have uh post
treatment data for cell line panels
in this case uh what we have is the
transcriptional profile for cell lines
after they've been treated with uh with
a drug and we can uh recognize the
transcriptional changes when these uh
after these drug treatments
uh and in some cases
then when we overlap those
post-treatment signatures with the
predictive biomarkers uh for other drugs
we find overlap so
to say that more simply
treatment with one drug may cause a
transcriptional change in a cell line
that now makes it look like it is going
to be sensitive to a second drug
we do mine that data
to help drive hypotheses uh for
potential combinations that
may be synergistic and so that's also
part of some of what we do in our cell
line panel design
if for example we need to
narrow down the number of drug
combinations as well as the numbers of
cell lines in the panel for the screen
that's a good question thank you
also um i think this question came in uh
in the beginning when you're talking
about designing the cell line panel um
how
how do you select the disease-specific
selling panels and they correlate with
clinical efficacy data
right
yes so
um as i mentioned uh you know in a
particular disease we recognize that the
genomic profile of a particular disease
can be quite unique
and so what we want to do is take into
account
that
diversity in the cell line panel so
you know if for example in uh in long
aveno
um as well as wanting to make sure that
we incorporate uh
the
map kinase operations which occur
relatively frequency we'd also want to
make sure we take into account uh egfr
pathway aberrations
alk events including alk fusions
and so
because of the amount of clinical data
we have
we have this very rich source that
allows us to understand what aberration
should be represented uh and then in the
sole line panel we don't represent them
at the same frequency they occur in the
clinical setting we represent them in a
way that allows us to address
uh whether or not they are important
from a statistical perspective
um
so so that's that's one
uh facet uh
the other part of the question again was
uh what's sandy i'm sorry the clinical
efficacy oh yeah and so the clinical
efficacy piece
uh again that comes from uh uh
particularly understanding uh resistance
population so with the uh
with the the biomarkers that we've
identified already from
many targeted uh and standard of care
therapy
uh in cell line panels we have these
banks of biomarkers that identify
for example
resistance or transcriptional signature
for mech resistance for example as i
illustrated in the slides
we can as well as mapping onto clinical
populations we also map onto cell line
uh the cell line data that we have in
early stages of the project so we can
identify cell lines which
we would predict by their biomarkers are
resistant
to a particular inhibitor
and weight the panel with cell lines
that exhibit that biomarker profile so
it becomes a testable biomarker
hypothesis
great that leads to another great
question what type of biomarkers do you
look for somatic mutation gene
expression profiling micro rna protein
all of them
yeah so uh in our standard pipelines we
look at uh mutation
uh copy number
expression
uh
expression uh expression of individual
genes
we roll our operations up into uh
pathways as well as individual genes uh
expression we use at the individual gene
level uh and at the uh
in terms of as part of a transcriptional
signature
um some of the other biomarkers so we
don't systematically right now include
micrornas
but if there are micrornas of interest
we can uh essentially go back and
address this in a hypothesis directed
way uh for any data set that we've
generated so
we can update our biomarker database
with that additional information to uh
just to support specific questions that
that a client may have so we're very
customizable from that perspective as
well
uh do you publish these bio markers
uh
uh well so uh
we do some proof of concept work
uh internally most of the work that we
do is uh done in collaboration obviously
with our clients
we often see that our
data is being used by our clients and we
recognize by the diseases
that they are uh going into
that they have utilized the results from
our data
we occasionally get to publish in
collaboration with our clients and our
partners uh so some of that data becomes
available uh we don't
systematically open up all of our
findings
and then finally uh
how do you take into account
physiologically relevant concentrations
of each drug in this type of analysis
yeah that's a great question too that
that is a challenge um if and but we
don't have that data for all of the
compounds that we're working with so in
some cases uh we'll apply
a somewhat arbitrary cut off
across the entire data set for every
compound
but if we do have data particularly on
the base compound
uh
the enhancee
in a combination screen
we can gate the data to only take into
account uh
doses that generate synergy uh below a
particular threshold so again i think
this points to
the the high degree of customization
that we can we can take on and we work
very closely with our clients in the
early stages of the project to make sure
they understand all of these
considerations and that we build and
scope the approach we're going to take
appropriately
and can manage some of these risks so
some cases we do it generically and in
some cases we can customize it based on
data either that we have or that our
client can provide
so dr robin i would like to thank you
again for your presentation today and to
everyone who's attended and your
wonderful questions uh if we did not get
to your question we will certainly
follow up with you and thank you for
those
uh we invite you to join us for our next
presentation in our webinar series uh
tomorrow uh 7 30 a.m pacific time uh
jeffrey shegeman and kelly bramlett from
thermo fisher scientific will give a
talk out of gene fusion so please join
us there
also uh if you'd like to learn more
about these companion bioscience
services and other products available
from live technologies please visit our
virtual booth we have attendees there
who can answer your questions literature
videos and things like that
that can be accessed from the exhibit
hall by using your home button on your
screen uh thank you again for attending
today and uh have a wonderful day thanks
thanks bye
all right
so you